[Music]
right now let's turn to dancing because
max was sidelined last night with his
injury so the pressure was on his
replacement Ellen Burstyn I got asked
about the man here stepping up filling
and obviously max went down with an
injury how quickly this guy step up can
you step up to the plate very fast max
wash Heather and Allan's jive from the
sidelines last night today he posted
this photo in a hospital gown and
confirmed Alan will fill in for him
again next week he's not sure when he'll
be back on the dance floor but he's in
ohio rehabbing his calf injury seeing
the same doctor Shana used when she hurt
her knee last season it was absolutely
incredible got me back in two weeks and
hopefully he'll do the same to max last
night Max's 11 we called sunshine made
his prime time debut his fiance Peter
brought the little guy to rehearsals
with pastor nick but dr. sharda for a
sec even though she and partner bought
her bolton swore to me they're single
this made us wonder
[Music]
I feel like I'm like and everybody else
watching something unfolding they tied
for fourth with Olympian Simone biles
and sasha farber comedian chris kattan
was the first to go he was in tears as
he revealed he broke his neck while
working 14 years ago here I want to see
this x-ray that's my back oh my gosh
part of what I used to do was physical
comedy but now I can't Chris told me he
thinks he would have been more
successful on the show if producers had
share his story with viewers from the
beginning
[Music]
you